in a video passed to the media by his
lawyer
jordan's prince hamza says this may be
the last time
he can contact anyone he says he's been
ordered by the army's chief to stay at
home
and that his phone and internet are
being cut off
he criticized jordan's leaders for
corruption and denied being part of any
conspiracy
a agenda there is no outside agenda
there is nothing on my part to affect
the country or outside plotting from
behind the scenes
we listen to these accusations over and
over again
this is only in order to make a smoke
screen over the retreat
and retraction that we witness in the
country every day
in our beloved country
[Music]
the video's release came shortly after
jordanian state tv
announced multiple arrests of former
senior officials on saturday night
jordan's army chief denied that prince
hamza was among them
but it did mention the arrests of the
former head of the royal court
basim award allah basum
was a long time confidant of the king
and
was at one time a minister uh of finance
and he has uh been arrested along with
several
others that were very close to the heart
of the court
it is not clear exactly what the role
that prince hamza played in this
but clearly there has been a division
inside the court that has
led the security forces to consider this
utmost
danger to the stability of jordan's
government
prince hamza is the half-brother of king
abdullah when their father king hussein
passed away in 1999
king abdullah was crowned and prince
hamza became the crown
prince of jordan however king abdullah
stripped him of this title
five years later following saturday's
arrest
regional leaders including the gcc were
quick to express solidarity
with king abdullah security personnel
have been deployed in the capital ahman
and other parts of the country there are
still more
questions than answers about the highly
unusual arrests
in what's long been considered a stable
country in the middle east
laura about a manly al jazeera let's
explore this further let's speak to
dalia farmer
she's a associate professor of political
science at long island university joins
us
from new jersey via skype dalia farming
welcome to the program
how do you read what's going on here
this is really a reflective of the
domestic internal rift and the wording
of the former crown prince
about corruption really is reflective of
what's been happening economically in
jordan
you know this king king abdullah has
been running
or talking about economic reform it's
not really political reform since he
took office
and you have a country that's hurting
economically it becomes a point where
opposition forces or opposition within
the government can rise and say
we haven't had political reform
especially since the arab spring
the economic reforms are failing today
for example
jordan's foreign debt has reached 35
billion it's
90 percent 95 of the country's gdp
and so what that does is it lends itself
to several challenges in the
pandemic era increasing refugee crisis
um the king had to implement some
austerity measures
so the country's been economically
hurting which has put him
on the kind of crosshairs of many
opposition forces inside
inside the court who see him as failing
compared to his father prince hamza
denies any wrongdoing
clearly the royal court think otherwise
well what he did was meet and uh he
referenced this in his
uh video he met with members of
tribal elders or tribal leaders and they
voiced their dissent and so him being in
that presence signaled that there could
be a rising internal rift but really a
threat remember he's the former crown
prince
the former the late king hussein wanted
him to be the crown prince and it was
king abdullah who removed him
and so there is especially in this time
of austerity
a comparison and it seems that the
former crown prince hamza sees himself
as the natural
um leader uh hearkening back to a time
of his father
where could this lead what are the
dangers
of what's happening here um
this is probably not going to lead
anywhere but what the king has to do
is probably raise some of the austerity
measures it's going to be very difficult
because these are the conditions the imf
has placed on him
to reduce that debt to gdp ratio
in order for the imf loans to continue
so domestically it's it's going to be a
tough time for the king
in terms of international relations and
where he stands in the region there
probably won't be any changes he's still
held favorably in the united states and
in the uk
he's a long-term ally he jordan shares a
very long border with
with israel and so there might not be
any change in status quo internationally
this is really a domestic rift
right i was going to say that the
regional leaders have been quick to
express solidarity with king abdullah
are there those nations who may be
less willing to stand alongside jordan
if the circumstances were right or
changed
well the interesting thing is that
although ahman is very vital to israel's
interest and its uh cornerstone you know
jordan is the custodian of east
jerusalem
um and shares a 335 kilometer border
with israel
the west bank essentially the king's
relationship with netanyahu has been
strained
and so the silence coming from israel is
is quite telling
it does not mean that they would want
someone aside from from king abdullah
but the silence
is quite telling and it just emblematic
of the rift for example just this past
week
we saw prime minister netanyahu
refuse to approve the supply of water to
jordan you saw the tit-for-tat over
airspace of the king was not allowed to
go to jerusalem
and then the next day they refused to
allow
netanyahu to fly to the uae his
helicopter over jordan
so it's been a very strange relationship
for the past couple of years
it does not mean that it will change
relations
but let's see what happens in israel
looking at what's happening in jordan
dalia farming great to get your
perspective do you appreciate that
thanks very much indeed
thank you